we begin with new hope though that the
coronavirus curve is starting to shift
it seems US officials report more than
three hundred and sixty-eight thousand
cases of the virus though the real
number could be much higher than that
the death toll has reached around 11,000
but as caseloads skyrocket nationwide
Tony there are potential signs of
progress right here in hard-hit New York
yeah they like what they see here in New
York the numbers of new hospitalizations
and intensive care admissions are
falling and in addition to that fewer
patients need breathing assistance
though health officials do warn that it
is still very early in this trend our
lead national correspondent David Beck
know is near the Comfort a Navy ship
deployed to help New York City hospitals
David good morning as if to underscore
the risks that these frontline workers
take to protect the public the comforts
very first coronavirus case as we
understand it was one of its own workers
that's true and that worker is isolated
separated from the rest of the people on
the ship for their safety and the
workers safety listen you know the
governor of New York had asked President
Trump can we start bringing Kovac
patients on the ship not just non koban
and the president has agreed and
patients will not only come from New
York they're gonna start coming from New
Jersey which is just right across the
river behind me and that's to help
relieve some of the pressure on the New
Jersey hospitals to
around the country this morning some
health systems are being pushed to the
brink in what could be the most critical
week for the coronavirus crisis yet an
EMS coordinator told us that he got an
emotional reaction when he helped to
bring in emergency staffing at an
overwhelmed New Jersey Hospital there
were tears in their eyes and easily to
see because all you're showing when
you're with full protection or your eyes
in other hot zones like Illinois they
added more than 1,000 cases in a single
day bringing the total there to more
than 12,000 cases in Michigan the
Detroit Free Press reports that the
state's largest hospital system has 1500
workers all showing kovetz symptoms
meanwhile the Henry Ford Health System
in Detroit says at least 700 of its
workers have already tested positive the
Army Corps of Engineers is now
transforming Detroit's Convention Center
into a one thousand bed field hospital
it will be one of 22 field hospitals
across 18 states in Pennsylvania a
nursing home reportedly says all 450 of
its residents are presumed to be
positive at a long-term care facility in
Maryland 14 deaths have been reported
and at a rehab facility in Virginia
they've lost 28 patients due to the
corona virus I think what we've learned
over the last month is just how much a
symptomatic transmission seems to be
contributing to the outbreak in New York
military personnel are now treating
coronavirus patients at the Javits
Convention Center in Manhattan we're
mobilizing in the same way that we
mobilize to go to war around the country
some health care workers have told CBS
News that their hospitals are warning
them not to talk to the media about the
lack of personal protective equipment or
hazardous work conditions but Michael
Pappas a resident at Mount Sinai
Hospital in New York City says he
believes he has a duty to speak out I do
not want it to be on my conscience that
I didn't speak out about what's going on
in these hospitals I would
either get sick and die knowing that I
spoke out whether or not I'm targeted
whether or not I lose my job
strong words from the doctor there
listen the Governor of New York has
extended the stay-at-home order through
the end of the month and he's actually
up the fines for people caught violating
that order and not socially distancing
to $1,000 that's what you'll pay if you
are ticketed by the police also the the
mayor of New York City is looking at
what would happen if the morgues here in
the city become overwhelmed they are not
there yet and there was a wild rumor
that bodies would be buried in parks
that is not the case the state and the
city says they are simply looking at one
place in the Bronx which is an island
where bodies could be buried if the
morgues are overwhelmed but we are not
there yet Anthony all right David thank
you